cher alsacienne charge alsacien nous
traversons l'une des pires crises de
notre histoire et l'alsace est en
première ligne services de santé
services de secours et de sécurité
militaire dans les collectivités dans
les entreprises dans les commerces dans
les associations tant de personnes sont
sur le pont avec grand courage et
dévouement pour faire face à l'urgence
pour sauver des vies ou bien pour
assurer les fonctions vitales au
quotidien de chacun je veux leur dire à
toutes et à tous notre respect et notre
infinie reconnaissance
un immense merci le conseil
départemental du haut rhin et mobilisées
jour et nuit pour être désengorgée les
eaux qui tout en trouvant des lits pour
rassembler y acquérir le matériel
indispensable pour les soignants pour
les ehpad et leurs résidents si fragile
vingt-six mille masques ont été
distribués ces derniers jours par le
département
dans cette crise nous avons tous un rôle
à jouer
une responsabilité respecter le
confinement et les mesures de sécurité
alors pour cent bien le bien de ceux que
vous aimez et le bien de tous chacun
doit rester chez lui rester chez soi
c'est à ce jour le seul remède à la
crise sanitaire en restant chez vous
vous protéger et vous protéger ceux que
vous aimez vous devez ainsi absolument
limiter au strict minimum
vos sorties pour les courses faites les
courses une fois par semaine maximum
s'il le faut si vous le pouvez
organisez-vous entre voisins en
respectant toujours les gestes barrière
le confinement a démarré il y a deux
semaines
bientôt il sera certainement prolongé je
sais que des centaines et des centaines
de solidarité s'opère partout en alsace
dans tous les secteurs de la société
entre voisins entre les entreprises
les institutions avec nos voisins
allemands et suisses
plus que jamais nous devons avoir la
meilleure attention pour les personnes
vulnérables qui nous entourent et qui
nous sont proches
cette entraide est indispensable à tous
et surtout elle doit se poursuivre
alsacienne alsaciens toujours plus
solidaire toujours plus unis nous
vaincrons l'épidémie